here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show okay Ralph first ones to
you do you support liberals rallying
around a libertarian like Rand Paul or
more of a centrist like Hillary Clinton
you mean general Aseema Hillary claim no
life support Rand Paul and foreign
military policy the Federal Reserve and
the bloated military budget right
all of which she's on the other side
who's LeBron who's conservative anymore
if only we could combine like the half
of Rand Paul we like with like Elizabeth
Warren wouldn't that be an awesome
candidate like a centaur like a center
what platforms do Democrats need to run
on to have any degree of success in the
2014 midterms let's ask the opposition
what would I think right now they're
running on impeachment and I think
therefore I think it's cynical but very
smart of them to do the White House has
been talking about impeachment non-stop
the Democratic camp well made he's
raised two million dollars they didn't
exactly make it up out of thin air there
are many Republicans who have brought up
that word and that congas a speaker
Speaker Boehner has been very clear
privately and publicly that this is not
happening and he's really the only one
that matters on this mmm okay and I
agree it is it is a political move for
them to I would be very stupid of us to
do that we're not gonna get a rant at
the end of the show in May saying please
do it because it's the one thing that
could save the Democrats you know we
tried that with Bill Clinton it didn't
work very well
no it did right yeah how do you think a
hypothetical president's atheism would
affect foreign policy in the US um
president Maher yeah like that'll ever
happen um well I mean atheists tend to
be ethicists we don't believe that
goodness is going you know is should be
anything but for the sake of itself we
don't think that our ass is going to get
saved because we have faith we have to
actually make our ethics in this world
so I would think it would be I would
think it'd be good
how worried should we be about Americans
going abroad and returning as suicide
bombers well we've seen American there
was a guy who blew himself up in Syria
this week an American and he by the way
he was railing against Americans working
too hard
he said Americans worked 40 50 60 hours
a week I'm like hey dude that's my bit
at the end of the show don't ya
he also said he didn't have any friends
poor guy that I mean that is a that is
the root of a lot of problems remember
the guy in Santa Barbara killed all
those people he needs some friends and
girlfriends it's in that age that is
such a dangerous age like 18 to 22 you
know you're you're not a kid anymore
you're finding your way in the world
it's like the beginning of your second
life you're you have nothing going for
you I'm going for my own life you know
and you're just very vulnerable for it
to anything I think that's why they join
these we need like an americorps of
girlfriends we'd wait I mean people like
you volunteer for two years to just be
the girls or ends to losers
I'll give some bipartisan support for
that I could use that actually no but it
really is true we need it gets better
not just robosexual right I like the
American right all right Chris I'm sorry
what isn't that right what the
AmeriCorps girlfriend know that it gets
better
oh it does it better but yeah why the
AmeriCorps girlfriend is like freshman
sophomore year for the girls and the
junior and senior year for the guys
listen this is why we have masturbation
right Ralph Nader I feel weird saying
that next to you I don't kind of feel
that I just said that out loud
I just made a jerk-off joke next to
Ralph Nader
office scene at all are you kidding I
was in fact I was reading that that when
when you were investigating when you're
invested in Corvair they tapped your
phones and tried to trap you with
prostitutes yeah Wow
how far did the prostitutes get nice not
as far as he would have gotten with you
that was back how did they do that did
they like dig a hole and put a carpet in
front of your door and then you follow
constitute clawing and attacking no that
sent me to cookie counter in a store oh
why sure we were having we're having a
discussion you want to come it's gonna
be on foreign affairs I think they were
talking about domestic affairs I need
and you knew that they were part I mean
at that time we knew you know how
there's a lot of stuff going on and so
what it helps it helped pass the auto
and highway safety but what did you do
it a minor concession I also feel a
little longer to do it like six guys
talking about what else should do we're
like Congress
all right so true just I was just
listening I'm good okay talking about
Ralph
this one says will you run in 2016
no now Jerry Brown is gonna look for if
Hillary falters watch for Jerry Brown Oh
Sylvia's fourth try he's very popular in
California you're leaving it to a
younger man yeah Chris what members of
Congress would you want on @midnight
oh please okay none of them I don't know
comedian we have comedian design yeah
yeah yeah we have comedian zone yeah
that would be a really boring like first
of all they would all have to get
together for about four weeks to decide
on how to answer each question yeah yeah
so rough these prostitutes wonderful and
tell me about the [ __ ] Lenny is this
do-nothing Congress representative of
what's in store for the future every
time a Democrat wins the presidency um
or maybe just anybody wins the
presidency I mean well I think certainly
Obama's first two years he was very
productive I didn't like what he was
producing but they were a very
productive Nancy Pelosi got a lot of
bills in the law obviously that's not
happening as much now but but I'll tell
you we you know for the past two years I
spent every day trying to pass
legislation a lot of it was bipartisan
we have about 45 Democrat bills that
pass the house one of which was actually
just passed last week was a barbara Lee
bill on that the Senate won't consider
and that's a real problem if the house
can pass bills that are bipartisan bills
some of them ought to be good ideas
maybe not all of them are but some of
them are and we just can't get things
through and the Senate has become a
legislative graveyard unfortunately so
this is they don't even consider
Democrat amendments in the Senate and
this is like the first day of the rest
of your life today right because
apparently so yes so so there'll be a
collection plate I believe I hope if you
had your druthers who would you work for
next I don't know I I was so fortunate
to work with Eric Cantor I think we suck
such a good guy who I think a lot of
people wouldn't wouldn't realize the
amount of time he spent in inner cities
visiting schools
time in medical research facilities and
hospitals you know things like that that
are really important do you think it
watch it
I believe that but I'm a big fan of
Marco Rubio I'm a big big fan of Bobby
Jindal and I also like the through
Hadron work for having worked for the
highest-ranking Jewish Republican and
the only African American Republican
National Committee Chair I like the fact
that we have a lot more diverse voices
than we did say ten years ago yeah yeah
you have one of each
thank you very much we'll see you in
September the time we film our ask
villainous guests your questions right
after the show
at hbo.com or on Twitter